what is going on wildlife warriors we
are located in the beautiful country of
Fiji right now this place is in the
South Pacific and is made up of over 300
islands this country is world-renowned
for pristine waters unique culture and
vibrant wildlife but I know that if I'm
going to experience the best that Fiji
has to offer I'm gonna have to get the
water
bull sharks are one of the most iconic
predators in the ocean they get their
name because of their stocking shape and
extremely aggressive behavior right away
I can see that there is a pecking order
to the feeding rights down here the
sharks will actually size each other up
before going after their food females
definitely rule down here as they
outgrow the males by almost a foot on
average the thought of taking the plunge
with nine-foot apex predators definitely
scare the hell out of me but it's
something I've always wanted to do by
being immersed in the Sharks ecosystem
I'm seeing firsthand just how important
they are to the world around them what
makes them a keystone species is that
there are drivers of evolution every
fish in this ecosystem has to be on high
alert
when these predators are around the fish
can't afford to get complacent because
that would ultimately lead
and it's for this reason and so many
others that I've fallen in love with
these sharks a by being out here by
being around them by being completely
immersed in their environment I'm
starting to appreciate them beyond
predators and as an integral part into
this underwater ecosystem what surprised
me the most however about this
experience was snuffed out graceful
these beautiful creatures are I enter
the water completely fearful but
over-the-top excited to get in there
with them and it left me with such a
deep appreciation for these sharks and
the world around them in to be honest
that is the best part about being a
wildlife filmmaker it's taking fear
turning it into curiosity and the
process always leaves you
deep appreciation for the natural world
[Music]
you
[Music]